at last in october 1925
after three years of excavating
tutankhamun's tomb howard carter and his
team begin to open the king's coffin
[Music]
lifting its lid exposes another shroud
when carter carefully peels that back he
discovers a second gilt coffin
even more magnificent
it has to be hoisted out of the first
[Music]
revealing decorations of iridescent blue
green and red glass inlay
[Music]
and inside that
a third coffin
but this one is covered with a thick
black perfumed resinous material
[Music]
with hammering chemical solvents and
heat carter's team gradually cleans it
what this reveals is incredible
[Music]
while the two outer coffins were crafted
from wood and covered in gold this one
is made of solid gold
winged goddesses protect the king
who holds the crook and flail symbols of
royal power
it takes eight men to lift its lid
to reveal the most incredible sight of
all
tutankhamun's mummy is covered in jewels
and crowned with an exquisite mask of
solid gold glass
and precious stones
and colorization really
brings out something
there is this amazing helmet mask of
solid gold
inlaid with glass
there's this great
scarab on its breast
there are gold hands there are inlaid
strips with magical formulae all over
the whole thing
nobody had ever seen this before
a pharaoh laid
exactly as he had been by
the priests three and a half thousand
years ago
the image of the gold mask shoots around
the world but nowhere is its impact
greater than in egypt itself
[Music]
this was a very highly emotional moment
in egypt
the discovery was used as a reassertion
of the egyptian identity and the proof
of us being the descendants of the
ancient egyptians which means that we're
not supposed to be ruled by any
foreigners
this meant that tutankhamun had to stay
in egypt and it were for the egyptians
as carter struggles to remove the mask
from the mummy its beard becomes
detached revealing boyish looks
and here we have an explanation of why
his tomb is so small
this is not the tomb of an old ruler
the remains
are of a teenage boy
later research suggests he died age 19.
there hadn't been time to finish an
official tube so the jumbled objects and
small tomb are explained
it was quickly assembled for the
untimely death of a young man
[Music]
you